[Musique]
merci Michel Val nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu de
la charante maritime membre du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain et
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères et on va bien sûr longuement
parler pendant cette demi-heure de la
situation en Israël d'abord on l'a vu
dans le journal hier avait lieu un débat
à l'Assemblée nationale il aura lieu au
Sénat cet après-midi on va en parler
Élisabeth borne qui a dit demander une
trêve humanitaire qui pourrait conduire
à un cesser le feu les populations ne
doivent pas payer pour les crimes des
terroristes c'est le message que vous
attendiez de la première ministre oui et
c'est un message que nous aurions
attendu plus tôt euh dans la mesure où
la première séance de question au
gouvernement qui a suivi le
déclenchement de de l'attaque terroriste
a donné lieu quand même à une
déclaration de la part de la première-
ministre étonnamment parce que j'aurais
pensé que la position traditionnelle
française aurait été adoptée plus vite
qui n'a pas été celle-ci hein qui a été
uniquement à destination de
d'Israël pour vous je veux pas employer
ces termes là moi je je je je laisse ça
à ceux qui ont pas envie de mettre de la
complexité dans les dans les explication
c'est une situation qui qui réclame deux
choses c'estd que vous ne pouvez pas
parler vous ne pouvez pas développer le
sujet si vous ne posez pas certains
principes et et la reconnaissance de
certains actes d'entré de jeu et une
fois que vous l'avez fait vous ne pouvez
pas pour autant être dans le simplisme
et il faut un peu comme dans une
équation si vous vous trompez au départ
sur le développement de C certains
facteurs vous pouvez pas développer
l'équation mais une fois que vous l'avez
fait ben vous pouvez aller dans le
détail donc pour dire les choses pro
anti et cetera c'est c'est c'est pas
comme ça que je
l'aborderai c'était en tout cas
émiplégique voilà parce qu'il faut poser
d'entrée de jeu je vais peut-être
enfoncer une porte ouverte mais
visiblement ça n'est pas évident pour
tout le monde on l' vu encore hier soir
à l'Assemblée nationale où c'est trop
évident pour certains je vais y revenir
il y a la question de la qualification
terroriste de de de l'attaque du Hamas
il y a la qualification de crime de
guerre
de manière assez évidente en tout cas on
peut dire qu'on a pas de doute sur le
fait que les enquêtes vont établir que
c'est un crime de guerre parce que ce
n'est pas à l'opinion d'établir ce qui
est un crime de guerre ou ce qui est un
crime contre l'humanité et ensuite il y
a la question du crime contre l'humanité
qui répond à une définition bien précise
qui pourrait être établi également une
fois que vous avez posé ça que vous avez
posé le droit à un état de se défendre
puisque c'est également un des aspects
fondamentaux du droit international mais
que quand vous dites ça forcément vous
incluez normalement vous incluez ce qui
pose sujet sur la déclaration de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale le
fait qu'on ne se défend pas n'importe
comment qu'il y a aussi un droit de la
guerre une fois que vous avez posé tout
ça vous pouvez rentrer dans les
explications et dans la complexité que
l'époque de manière générale n'aime pas
et et vous dites que y brune Pilet elle
est allé trop loin sur le droit d'Israël
à se défendre sans préciser qu'il
fallait qu'Israël quand on fait de la
diplomatie parlementaire du droit de
Guer alors là aussi je vais poser des
choses c'estàd que avant d'évoquer la
situation de de l'analyse sur le voyage
de Madame euh la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il faut poser le
fait que la foule que désigne Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'est pas plus la France que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est la République à
lui tout seul on n'est pas la France à
soit tout seul quand on est une foule et
on n'est pas la République à soit tout
seul on va pas revenir sur sur cet
épisode là une fois qu'on a dit ça on a
le droit d'avoir une opinion comment
dire qui n'est pas binaire sur le voyage
de madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et probablement que le faire
avant la visite du président de la
publique le faire de manière également
émiplégique avec avec les parlementaires
avec lesquels elle y est allée je veux
dire elle est pas allée avec les les
plus nuancés pour le le le dire de
manière ophimistique et notamment meer
Habib on on pourrait revenir si si vous
voulez et bien et bien non je trouve que
cette diplomatie parlementaire elle a
pas fait preuve de beaucoup de
diplomatie c'est le droit de la
présidente de séparation des pouvoirs
elle a le droit de le faire mais on peut
aussi avoir une opinion sur
l'opportunité on va évidemment revenir
sur les les réactions de la France
insoumise mais du coup ellisabeth borne
il y aura un débat au Sénat cet
après-midi qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de plus de la PR le le le discours qui a
été prononcé par la première ministre
hier à l'Assemblée nationale est un
discours qu'elle aurait pu prononcer
d'entrée de jeu dès dès le déclenchement
des hostilités dès qu'on a pu comprendre
ce qui se passait à peu près dans les
grandes lignes et donc sur le discours
d'hier soir très franchement là pour le
coup il y a une position qui est un peu
moins probablement mu par l'affect
immédiat et qui est la position
tradition de de la France avec en plus
un une pesée au trébucher sur la
qualification de de ce qui s'est passé
je je trouve que la première ministre a
dit tout ce qu'il fallait dire elle
n'est pas allé au-delà de ce qu'il
aurait fallu dire quel va être le
message du Parti socialiste c'est
Patrick hanner votre président de groupe
qui prendra la parole qu'est-ce que vous
avez envie de dire le le le message il
est pareillement je connu d'avance quand
on on essaie de se placer dans une
perspective de long terme c'est les les
deux états dans les limites antérieures
à 67 c'est la position traditionnelle de
de la France mais s'ajoute à cela et
c'est là qu'il y aura probablement des
nuances entre les différentes
expressions politiques comme hier à
l'Assemblée nationale la conclusion
qu'on en tire par rapport à l'état de
l'opinion en France et et par rapport à
la façon dont on va faire en sorte de ne
pas importer ce conflit sachant qu'il y
a des des des familles politiques et je
ne dis pas que l fill parce que dans
tout le monde est focalisé sur sur LFI
et et il est normal de mettre les choses
au carré parce que ce qui se passe est
inadmissible mais il y a des familles
politiques qui souhaitent en leur fort
intérieur le le le le comment dire que
le feu soit attisé par une importation
du conflit vous pensez à qui écoutez
franchement le discours de Marine Le Pen
hier soir qui vous vous vous le liriez
sur le papier vous sauriez pas que c'est
c'est le discours de Marine Le Pen c'est
trop gros c'est qu' un parti qui a été
fondé par une personne condamnée à
plusieurs reprises un parti dont la
réussite entre guillemets a été de faire
converger les différentes chapelles de
l'extrême droite française au Front
national euh qui pour moi est tout pour
moi le rassemblement nationale est la
continuité du frond national au frond
national c'était la rencontre entre les
catotrad les anti les pro-arabes
anti-israéliens pour des raisons
d'antisémitisme les pro-israéliens pour
des raisons de de d'islamophobie ou les
païen hein
qui quasiment faisait des rites païens
au moment des solstices donc cette
convergence là fait qu'aujourdhui Marine
Le Pen elle change tout simplement
d'ennemis à désigner et PE luich chaud
si aujourd'hui ils doivent être copains
avec Israël pour désigner les les
musulmans de de France ou d'ailleurs ça
leur va ils ont besoin d'avoir quelqu'un
contre et donc le discours de Marine Le
Pen était tellement aux antipode de de
ce qui est la matrice du rassemblement
national que çaen était ridicule on va
évidemment revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé hier à l'Assemblée et sur les
positions de la France insoumise mais
d'abord l'événement d'aujourd'hui c'est
cette visite d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël
le chef de l'État qui a atterri ce matin
à TelAviv on va en parler d'abord avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
Luc Chaillot bonjour merci d'être avec
nous journaliste international au group
bras les journaux régionaux de l'Est de
la France Emmanuel Macron et donc en
Israël qu'est-ce qu'on sait de ce
voyage bonjour eu bien écoutez c'est un
voyage à haut risque hein sur le plan
politique et et diplomatique qu'Emmanuel
Macron effectue parce qu'il a placé la
barre très haut en terme d'objectif il
avait dit encore vendredi dernier qu'il
voulait essayer d'obtenir des choses
utiles sa visite s'annonce aussi
périeuse dans un contexte très qui est
très inflammable avec une situation
politique intérieure potentiellement
explosive la question en fait du du du
conflit israëlo-palestinien est très
sensible en France où je le
rappelle la France compte à la fois la
première communauté juive et la première
communauté musulmane en Europe et
d'ailleurs le le le chef de l'État
l'avait dit jeudi dernier devant des
jeunes le risque c'est que le conflit
s'importe chez nous et qu'on se divise
euh
Emmanuel Macron va arriver à téaviv avec
une proposition de trêve humanitaire et
l'espoir d'obtenir un cesser le feu qui
permettrait de faciliter la libération
des otages qui sont détenus par le Hamas
tout en apportant évidemment un répi aux
civiles de Gaza mais on le sait Israël
et les États-Unis ne sont pas d'accord
avec cette proposition et il ils demande
d'abord la libération des otages avant
tout cesser le feu et puis euh
évidemment Emmanuel Macron va essayer de
convaincre les pays de la région
d'éviter une escalade et un risque de
propagation de la guerre et notamment au
sud du Liban il se pourrait d'ailleurs
que Emmanuel Macron poursuivre sa visite
au Proche-Orient avec une étape au Liban
mais ce n'est pas confirmé pour
l'instant euh son autre objectif c'est
évidemment à plus long terme d'obtenir
un consensus international qui
conduirait à une reprise du processus de
paix en vue de la création d'un État
palestinien à côté de celui d'Israël
cette solution à deux états euh est
soutenue de long de longue date par la
France euh l'Élysée disait hier soir la
France veut ouvrir une perspective
politique pour la seule solution
possible celle de deux états vivant côte
à côte en paix et en sécurité et
l'Élysée a également demandé un arrêt
des colonisations toutefois ce ce
évidemment cette solution à deux état
paraît de de plus en plus difficile de
plus en plus difficile
euh parce que on assiste évidemment à
une accélération de la colonisation don
les teritoires occupés et qui qui et des
expulsions forcé de Bédoin par les
colons et l'armée israélienne il se sont
multiplié depuis l'attaque du Hamas le 7
octobre donc le ce plan de paix dont
rêve Emmanuel Macron semble très
lointain au moment où les les r
d'Israéliens redoupent sur la bande de
Gaza en attendant une offensive
terrestre qui paraît inévitable et lu
vous question just monsieur le sénateur
oui monsieur le sénateur j'avais une
question pour vous est-ce que cette
visite d'Emmanuel Macron euh arrive au
bon moment et est-ce qu'elle peut faire
avancer les
choses d'abord Emmanuel Macron est
obligé d'y aller si on raisonne encore
en Auton noir comme je le faisais tout à
l'heure il est obligé d'y aller euh on a
un nombre de victimes françaises qui est
le plus important depuis l'attentat de
Nice donc il est bien évident que le
Président de la République doit y aller
il n'y a pas de de sujet là-dessus il
est important qu'il y aille avant
l'offensive terrestre si offensive
terrestre il doit y avoir et visiblement
c'est ce qui est préparé par les frappes
qui sont quand même d'une ampleur euh
d'une ampleur euh qui qui pose enfin
comment dire qu' doit tous nous
interroger en tout cas nous nous
interpeller donc c'est bien qu'il y
aille avant euh c'est pas terrible
qu' ne se soit pas coordonné dans la
majorité qu'il y aille après la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
parce que si elle avait préparé le
terrain ça se serait vu hein si ça avait
été une visite de de préparation et
pardon pour l'expression de de déminage
ça n'a visiblement pas été le cas après
quel est le bon moment je crois avec une
mensuéude que je n'ai pas d'habitude
pour Emmanuel Macron qui quand même pour
l'instant ona pas marqué l'histoire par
sa politique diplomatique je crois qu'il
y a pas de moment précis qui soit
meilleur qu'un autre on va quand même
pas faire la course à l'échalotte pour
se dire il faut y aller avant les
Allemands il faut y aller avant les
Américains tout le monde doit jouer dans
ce dans ce concert là un rôle un rôle le
plus intelligent le plus intelligent
possible ce qui serait important c'est
que Emmanuel Macron puisse montrer qu'en
plus du contact avec le les autorités
israéliennes et et l'opposition aussi ce
qui est une bonne chose parce qu'en
Israël les oppositions les majorités se
font se défond c'est un régime très
parlementaire euh mais qui qu'il est un
contact si possible le plus concret
possible avec l'Autorité
palestinienne merci lu on va évidemment
continuer nous à parler de ces sujets
merci c'est dans les journaux du groupe
hbra Luc évidemment à lire on regarde
une des unes du groupe ébrra celle du
dauphinet Macron en Israël mission
impossible c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Luc Chaillot
d'avoir été avec nous on continue à
parler de ces sujets Quentin calmé nous
[Musique]
rejoint
Bontin bonjour Quentin on a parlé de la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël
d'importants enjeux oui enfin c'est ça
effectivement on évoquait avec Luc
Chaillot hein le fait que effectivement
c'est un déplacement sur de jours avec
sans doute la visite d'un autre État
alors Luc évoquait la piste du Liban on
parle aussi de l'Égypte il faut dire
effectivement qu'il y a une forme de
pression vous disait le chef d'État
était obligé d'y aller aussi parce qu'il
y a eu ces visites d'État d'autres chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement occidentaux en
Israël on a vu bien bien sûr Joe Biden
se rendre en Israël on a vu aussi le
premier ministre britannique Richi sunac
le chanelier allemand Olaf Scholz et
même la présidente du Conseil italien
c'était samedi Georgia melony il était
donc en fait logique on le comprend
qu'Emmanuel Macron et bien ajoute son
nom à cette liste de personnalité venu
soutenir l'État hébreux il faut dire
aussi monsieur valet que il y avait
certains responsables politiques qui
appelaient le président de la République
à se rendre sur place à notre micro
jeudi c'était le cas de Roger carucci
sénateur LR et président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël au Sénat il avait
exhorté le chef de l'État à se rendre
sur place d'ailleurs regrettant que
l'Élysée attende il avait dit c'est
dommage parce que c'est maintenant qu'il
faut y aller c'est maintenant qu'il faut
faire pression sur tous les acteurs pour
que les choses se calment ce n'est pas
après Emmanuel Macron il avait mis des
conditions au fait de se rendre dans
cette région voilà c'est cela c'est ce
qu'on avait compris depuis la semaine
dernière l'Élysée avait assuré que la
visite pourrait effectivement se faire
dans les prochains jours mais avec des
conditions il l'avait dit lors d'un dépl
en Albanie écoutez le chef de l'État
c'était mardi dernier le 17
octobre pour ma part je me rendrai dans
la région dès que je considérerai que
nous avons un agenda
utile et des actions très concrètes à y
conduire je vais continuer les
consultations les
discussions mais ma volonté c'est de
pouvoir m'y déplacer quand nous pourrons
obtenir un accord
concret soit sur la nonescalade soit sur
les questions humanitaires parmi les
questions humanitaires un dossier majeur
celui des otages la France est toujours
sans nouvelle de SEP ressortissants qui
pourrai faire partie des otages sur les
220 qui a dénombré l'armée israélienne
on verra donc le message politique
qu'envoie également Emmanuel Macron sur
la situation très critique des civils à
Gaza Emmanuel Macron il se revendique
d'une position d'équilibre dans ce
dossier entre soutien au droit d'Israël
à se défendre et appelle au respect du
international voilà vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer sur ce plateau mais
effectivement la position de la France a
été rappelée notamment mercredi en
audition au Sénat Catherine colon la
chef de la diplomatie française a lancé
d'abord un appel à la responsabilité
pour éviter l'escalade et un embrasement
régional puis à la rappeler et bien la
position de la France he qui est
constante depuis 40 50 ans il faudra
prendre en compte le droit absolu
d'Israël à la sécurité a-t-elle dit tout
comme le droit des Palestiniens à
disposer d'un état nous ne changeons pas
de conviction et que c'est la paix qui
apportera à la sécurité qu'il faut se
diriger vers une solution à deux états
où Chac chacun pourra vivre en paix et
en sécurité écoutez également ellisabeth
borne cette fois-ci c'était à
l'Assemblée nationale lors du débat avec
tous les groupes politiques vous parlez
de sa position on va la
réécouter si le terrorisme doit être
combattu la réponse des démocraties doit
être juste même dans les combats les
plus dures les plus âpres nous ne devons
jamais perdre de vue ce qui fait n de
nous des démocraties nos valeurs le
respect de l'État de droit comme le
droit international
humanitaire notre amitié et notre
solidarité avec le peuple israélien nous
oblige à formuler cet appel Israël ne
doit pas tomber dans le piège du
Hamas plusieurs milliers de Palestiniens
sont morts à Gaza dont de nombreux
enfants les 2 millions d'habitants de
Gaza sont dans une situation d'une
extrême gravité ces milliers de VI
fauchés nous ne les oublions pas je ne
les oublie pas voilà on verra maintenant
comment le message du chef de l'État et
bien est porté dans la journée
d'aujourd'hui et demain et si au-delà de
l'aspect symbolique sa visite se solde
par des des avancées à la fois
humanitaires ou diplomatiques ouais
Michel Valet et manuel Macron qui veut
appeler à la reprise d'un véritable
processus de paix est-ce que c'est le
moment on entend Benjamin netanahou il
veut venger l'attaque dont a été victime
Israël alors pour le coup ça c'est trop
ça ça arrive tard c'est-à-dire que bah
je vous renvoie au au rapport qui a fait
suite à la visite de la délégation du
Sénat l'année dernière en Israël et et
en Palestine où le le rapport analyse
qui était de la commission des affaires
étrangères analyse l'année dernière la
fragilité de la situation et pour autant
la nécessité de trouver des moyens de de
de réaccrocher de de remettre dans le
mécanisme tous ceux qui qui doivent
l'être pour poursuivre le le le travail
vers la solution euh à deux états euh le
problème c'est que la diplomatie
française et les les chancelleries
européennes de manière régionale les
Américains pour d'autres raisons ont
laissé filer depuis plusieurs années et
puis on pensait finalement que tant que
le problème ne n'était pas dans une
actualité la plus brûlante et bien on ne
voyait pas les 2 millions de personnes à
Gaza qui sont quand même dans une
situation où le terme de prison à ciel
ouvert qui a été réemployé par Dominique
de Villepin je je renvoie tout le monde
vers l'interview de Dominique de
Villepin l'entretien sur France interre
et puis Vedrine ces derniers temps et
Jean-Louis bourlange hier voyez j'en
mets pour tout le monde au centre à
droite à gauche sur ce sujet-là enfin je
je veux dire le le cette question
humanitaire elle est elle est
fondamentale mais on l'a laissé filer
parce queon a eu le sentiment que
l'agenda international était autre donc
Emmanuel Macron a raison mais on arrive
aussi après plusieurs années où on ne
s'est plus préoccupé dans les exécutives
de se de de réaccrocher de réenclencher
la question des des deux états et quand
les États-Unis eux-mêmes ont pour
priorité de transférer l'ambassade
américaine à Jérusalem si vous voulez
c'est
oui ça n' pas été modifié derrière comme
beaucoup de choses avec Biden cétait pas
vraiment l'état d'esprit mais les les
États-Unis juste un mot puisque vous en
parl qui rejetteent les appels au CC
lefeu pour le coup et qui disent qu'une
trêve bénéficierait au Hamas ils ont toi
c'est très compliqué parce que hier
c'était un des sujets c'est à peu près
le seul angle que Mathilde Panau a
trouvé pour pour cogner sur le sur le
gouvernement de dire vous n'avez pas
prononcé cesser le feu en fait c'était
une façon de répondre coup pour coup sur
l'accusation tout tout à fait fondé et
fondamental sur le fait qu'il n'avait
pas prononcé le terme de terrorisme
s'agissant du du Hamas donc on parle de
trêve
humanitaire à ce stade ce sont les mots
de la première- ministre mais enfin si
on fait une trêve c'est pour pouvoir
enclencher ensuite on va pas arriver
alors que Israël a
vécu probablement le plus grand
traumatisme depuis la la Seconde Guerre
mondiale on peut pas arriver en leur
disant vous savez quoi on va commencer
par inesser le feu la diplomatie c'est
aussi de la psychologie et parfois de la
psychologie interpersonnelle avec avec
certains gouvernements et en
l'occurrence avec Israël dont il
m'importe de dire parce qu'on parlait de
poser les termes dans l'équation que
c'est un gouvernement qui gouverne avec
l'extrême droite faut faut aussi le dire
mais il existe en Israël des formations
politiques qui ne sont pas extrémistes
il y a notamment une gauche travailliste
israélienne donc c'est important de ne
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
sac de parler à tout le monde mais là
parler à des gouvernants israéliens en
leur expliquant on va commencer par le
cesser le feu je comprends qu'il y ait
qu'il puisse y avoir une différence
d'approche entre pays occidentaux à
notre micro Roger carucci la semaine
dernière évoquer une autre difficulté
c'est celle de négocier avec le Hamas
puisque et bien ce sont eux qui sont les
représentants d'une politique principaux
à Gaza comment est-ce qu'on peut
négocier une solution à deux états avec
un interlocuteur qui est sur la liste
des des entités terroriste mais ça c'est
le piège dans lequel on se trouve par
manque de travail euh sur la région
c'est que normalement ce n'est pas avec
le Hamas qu'on devrait discuter ce sont
avec des gens ce sont avec des gens qui
ont renoncé au terrorisme il y a
plusieurs dizaines d'années pour rentrer
dans un processus politique mais bon on
a tellement pris de haut le fatal
Autorité palestinienne qui elle-même n'a
probablement pas fait le nécessaire pour
apparaître comme un acteur légitime que
les choses se sont déporté il y a le
Hamas et le Djihad islamique parce que
si quand bien même on se mettrait je ne
veux pas le
prononcer on peut pas discutter avec des
teroristes ou avec le Hamas on peut
chercher des portes d'entrée avec des
gens qui peuvent peut-être essayer de
leur expliquer que ils ont un intérêt
d'une manière ou d'une autre à à à
baisser l'intensité des choses vous avez
à côté du Hamas le jihad islamque don
depuis début de la crise on voit que
même en 6 Jord le Hamas sort presque
renforcé avec des manifestations qui en
6 Jordanie voilà célèbre le Hamas ou
mais il faut pas comment dire non
seulement il faut pas s'en on peut le
regretter profondément après il y a
l'explication il ne faut pas s'en
étonnner puis il faut un peu se
décentrer de notre côté un peu
européocentré
de d'occidentaux vous avez sur l'Ukraine
par exemple le nombre de pays qui ne
soutiennent pas l'Ukraine on on essaie
de ne pas le voir en Europe seulement
quand on regarde les votes à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies il faut
comprendre qu'on parle à une partie du
monde qui n'a plus exactement le même
système de de pensée la communauté
internationale c'est un but mais elle
n'est pas vraiment existante en ce
moment donc il faut acter ce que vous
venez de dire pour comprendre comment
discuter avec qui discuter et quand même
rien d'étonnant à ce que vous ayez des
des des pays arabes ou de culture
arabo-musulmane dans lesquels il y a un
soutien à la Palestine qui qui qui est
très très fort et et discuter avec le
Hamas notamment sur la question des
otages ça reste Mo j'ai pas dit discuter
avec le c'est une question c'est une
question que je vais vous poser c'est
c'est la priorité d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est la libération des otages est-ce
que pour cela il faut discuter avec le
Hamas euh on on ne peut pas dire euh on
ne peut pas avoir une un discours public
consistant à dire qu'on négocie avec des
terroristes donc on passe par le Qatar
donc on passe par des personnes qui
peuvent parler et expliquer que c'est
quand même dans leur intérêt euh
d'essayer de lâcher du l'est ce qui est
certain c'est qu'un gouvernement doit
toujours tout faire pour libérer seses
ses nationaux et ses otages et il est
normal que le Président de la République
en fasse une priorité en revanche il ne
va pas revenir dans son avion dans 48 he
avec avec les otages le le la vie n'est
pas une série télévisée et et et ni la
ni la simplicité des chaînes d'infonue à
propos du débat au Parlement qui se joue
cet après-midi au Sénat on avait vu une
initiative de la droite sénatoriale qui
voulait proposer une résolution avec
d'autres gr group politique afin d'avoir
un message clair et même un vote au sein
du Sénat notamment pour condamner le
Hamas c'est pas la solution qui a été
retenue par le gouvernement avec ce
débat l'article 50-1 et donc sans votes
la droite sénatoriale le regrette
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
séquence d'ailleurs vous vous étiez pas
associé vous à cette résolution la
gauche je je vais vous donner une
opinion qui est tout à fait personnelle
parce que je je je ne sais pas mais je
devine quel serait l'opinion de mon
groupe sur le sujet je trouve bien qu'il
y ait un débat c'est c'est d'ailleurs la
première ministre l'a dit hier soir à
l'Assemblée c'est pour ça que je je je
pense que les choses sont moins moins
tranchées que ça il est important qu'il
y ait un débat pour que chaque formation
politique puisse dire quel est son
positionnement et qu'on ne se contente
pas des tweets il a un moment où c'est
bien que les formations politiques qui
représentent les Français et la nation
puissent dire quel est le positionnement
des un ça aurait pas été plus fort avec
un vote non mais vous savez le discours
le discours des différents partis des
groupe politique ce soir au Sénat ne
laissera pas d'ambigué sur ce qu'aurait
pu être un vote justement puisque vous
parlez
évidemment on va revenir sur ce tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a fait beaucoup
réagir à la classe politique sur la vie
brune pivé vous nous avez dit ce que
vous pensez de la visite de y brun pivé
mais lui il dit Madame brun pivé campe à
Tel Aviv pour encourager le massacre pas
au nom du peuple français c'est
inadmissible c'est
inadmissible d'abord sur la
captation sur l'idée que que Mélenchon a
lui tout seul je l'appelle Mélenchon
parce que comme il a l'habitude
d'appeler les gens uniquement par leur
nom de famille c'était une tradition
révolutionnaire c'est c'est vrai mais je
pense que mélanchant aussi en tête
peut-être symboliquement mais qu' à
l'époque de la révolution on tranché les
têtes donc non on peut pas faire
disparaître du champ politique comme ça
les gens qui ne vous reviennent pas
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche et non
on ne veut pas réduire la France à soit
tout seul je c'est pas parce qu'on est à
deux doigts d'être au second tour de la
présidentielle qu'on représente la
France ça soit tout seul donc c'est
est-ce qu'il y a de l'antisémitisme dans
ce tweet et bien s'il n'y en a pas et si
l'inconscient a parlé ou si sa langue à
forché ce que je ne crois pas je pense
que les mots sont choisis oui bien sûr à
mais comme avec le le rappeur là don je
ne comprends pas que que que mes
camarades écologistes et persisté au
fait de d'inviter un Tyam don on soit
pas sûr qu'il est clair sur sur le terme
de rescapé enfin tout ça est totalement
ubesque en tout cas s'il ne l'est pas on
peut toujours derrière dire ce n'est pas
mon intention je change volontiers le
mot et ça ne change rien au fait que je
condamne la visite ou je critique la
visite bon voilà oui parce que la police
des mot si vous voulez la police des
mots je pense que comme on dit au Québec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourrait se garder
une petite gêne est-ce que parce qu'il a
parce qu'il la pratique est-ce que du
coup le PS doit aller plus loin qu'une
simple suspension et qu'un simple
moratoire est-ce qu'il faut rompre avec
la France insoumise avec mench alors je
ne suis pas dans les instances
nationales du Parti socialiste je suis
adhérant du Parti socialiste et je le
suis depuis bien des années et je ne
suis jamais euh aller voir ailleurs et
c'est mon parti politique néanmoins je
suis pas dans les instances nationales
donc je vais vous dire deux choses un je
constate qu'elle a été le vote unanime
de l'ensemble des des des des des forces
structurées au sein du parti socialist
euh oui enfin la résolution la
résolution a été a été a été travaillée
et elle elle donc elle a été adoptée il
y a un vote elle s'impose il est pas
interdit de penser que le moratoire ne
reviendra jamais à la situation hantée
et je le souhaite que ça ne revienne pas
à la situation
hantée ça suffit non mais ça suffit on
peut pas être mélangé à ça déjà que
quand on avait parfois des candidatures
au législatif ou dans certaines
élections locales où il y avait le NPA
qui d'une manière ou d'une autre
soutenait quoi on a pu avoir au moment
des municipal le NPA qui moi j'ai
toujours considéré que les trotskistes
n'étaient pas des gens qui qui
privilégient la démocratie bah là sur le
soutien non pas à la Palestine sur le
soutien à à l'initiative du Hamas il
faut il faut avoir rompre si c'est pas
déjà fait mais il faut avoir une
position ultra claire donc on avance il
y a cette question de moratoire mais on
on ne pourra pas revenir en arrière
enfin c'est c'est la gauche républicaine
ce n'est pas ça merci Michel Valy merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure merci
qutin merci à tout à l'heure dans le
club